what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future alright so one of the
big questions that I've had is this
probably think I'm gonna release before
we really like jump in at Christmas but
one of the big requests that I've had is
to make a video with taken related
content least I'm pretty sure that's how
you pronounce it I'm pretty sure it's
taken maybe a stack and I don't know I
was having climbed at home Steve Oh
that'd be an amazing title for a video
Steve the son of Wolverine Wolverine had
a son named Steve it's like yeah man
like he's just a tax guy definitely
doesn't just do taxes didn't really have
anything special going on he's just kind
of just hanging out then he screwed up
Wolverines taxes one day so we killed
him but in any event I'm beginning that
request a lot a lot of people really
like the character of Dakin now Dakin as
you guys know him was really kind of
fleshed out in daniel ways run of
Wolverine Origins which is like this
fifty issue run that just covers like
all these missing memories of Wolverines
life as well as like original sin and
subsequent stories that came around
during that time but he was originally
introduced under Jeph Loeb and Wolverine
vol 3 issue number 54 I think I'm not
gonna swear to that but I'm pretty sure
it's the case somewhere around there
somewhere along those lines but instead
of by jumping into like a whole volume
of Wolverine and covering all these
things that lead up to the introduction
of akin only to turn around and see a
flaw because nobody really cares what I
instead wanted to do here was basically
go through and do the what-if story
where Wolverine killed his son now what
this does is especially kind of wrapped
around into the early days of his life
and it turns history on its head a
little bit what I mean here is this
story was written by a guy named Rob
Williams now as far as I know Rob
Williams really just kind of delved into
independent comics he really did a lot
of indie stuff and he's only really done
like a handful of Marvel comics and I
think right now he's working with DC and
vertigo but the idea here was that when
Dakin's batch story was slowly revealed
over the course of a series of
publications it had been established
that his birth came by way of a massacre
to be honest the Winter Soldier Bucky
Barnes had basically been sent to kill
the pregnant wife of Wolverine he
succeeded in doing that while Wolverine
was gone and then dick it was basically
taken from the corpse of his mother and
then dropped off at a wealthy family's
house and it was really kind of like the
earliest days
Dagan that's how we kind of grew into
that what this story does is it says
that didn't happen instead Wolverine
basically came home while each he was
being attacked she did die but then he
absolutely slaughtered Bucky Barnes this
is kind of a crazy situation because Rob
Williams in his writing that's kind of
weird I wouldn't say it's continuity
errors so much that because this is a
what-if story this is not the same set
of events so what I mean here is for
those of you guys who are new to Marvel
Comics what ifs are usually like an
alternate reality DC has Elseworlds
where it's just like here's a story
where like Batman and the Justice League
become Green Lantern's but they're not
tied into the main DC continuity it's
not like the ring of a band saw or went
to Bruce Wayne instead of Hal Jordan and
that's the continuity it happens that
way but it's not tied into things with
Marvel's what if they tied into the main
continuity to they say all things
progress normally and then you know this
event happened and that seems to be what
happens here but the idea of Wolverine
killing Bucky Barnes is kind of a big
deal because Wolverine fought alongside
Steve Rogers Captain America in World
War two he fought alongside Bucky Barnes
as well as so he's basically killing an
ally that he fought with during World
War two the problem with this is that
for Wolverine is pretty easy to distance
himself from the idea I'm killing a
friend because this is after the
supposed death of Bucky Barnes when he
was taken by the Russians and
transformed into the assassin known as
the Winter Soldier so because of this
the memory that he had of his former
life are essentially gone not only that
Bucky Barnes had never really faced an
enemy like Wolverine before and that's
prevalent in this story when he's just
like you're not supposed to be here and
he's terrified for his life because
Wolverine is a guy that after his claws
first popped you know after he took off
from his family and he basically tried
to live a peaceful life it was one of
these things where he just wanted to
stay out of the public eye he was like
the Hulk he just wanted to be left alone
he wanted a peaceful life but woe betide
the poor soul that came along and
screwed that up and that's what happened
with Bucky Barnes he took the wrong
contract and the result is that
Wolverine basically decapitates enough
from here the tough thing for Logan is
that he literally has to cut his wife
open and take taken out and that's where
things start to differentiate because in
the main stories and again I'm not gonna
get too deep into this on the off chance
of this videos stupidly popular people
want me to do taken but essentially the
story unfolded in a different way to
where an emag matic being basically came
along some guy that we didn't know who
it was at first came along and took
bacon out of his mother's body and then
dropped him off at a family and so with
Wolverine taking him for him this this
is a crushing experience for a
and this changes everything about his
character I mean this will impact his
role in the x-men the whole nine yards
because now he's basically a father and
that was really Daniel weighs emphasis
when he said okay you know let's focus
more on Dakin let's flush his character
out almost the entirety of Wolverine
Origins was this idea who of rain
basically reflecting on the history of
his life and then I think by issue
number 10
bacon popped up and he was like oh my
god I'm a father and he had to basically
change his ways and that's what happens
here he looks back at his life you know
a life of violence basically living for
the enjoyment of it sure you know he
killed people but he also wanted a
peaceful life but it was the idea that
Wolverine could afford to be selfish he
was for all intents and purposes
immortal and so he knew in the back of
his head even if he didn't want to
acknowledge it that it eats you have a
child and the two of them raised it a
time would come that if that child did
not inherit his healing factor he would
outlive both his wife and his son before
worrying that wasn't the issue it was he
just wants to have a normal life he just
wants to have a family he wants to be as
human as he possibly can but looking at
this child he basically said Santa says
I can't just live for myself anymore
they can't just be me anymore now I've
got someone that looks up to me
I effectively have to cast off my old
ways and I literally just need to run to
the furthest corners of the world and
that's what they do they run to Tibet I
mean they run to the third of the world
and they essentially just kind of hide
out there now the reason why I bet was
chosen is because it's such a difficult
place to get you I mean you've got to
get through the Himalayas assuming you
could survive the experience and then
you've got to find your way to where it
is they are in Tibet and so because of
the fact that is so isolated and so
hidden the likelihood of anybody who had
grudges Wolverine Lady Deathstrike
any of those characters nukes Sabretooth
the likelihood of any of them finding
Wolverine is slim to none and so during
this time he basically raises his son as
best he can he teaches in prayer he
teaches him the humble nature of life he
teaches him to respect life to respect
the value of all living things to very
much be at home with himself the problem
with this is that Wolverine is
effectively ignoring what it was that
made him who he was and this is why Rob
Williams writing is so good is because
it begs the question is the violent
nature of Wolverine just a part of who
he is is it just his nature to be
violent there's a really really good
parable that I heard once called the
Scorpion in the Frog any of you guys who
have heard this bear with me for a
second because a lot of people haven't
but it really represents these opposing
dichotomies of Wolverines desire for
peace and Wolverines inherent violence
the pair of
goes like this one day there was a
scorpion sitting on the side of a
riverbank one day and he was trying to
figure out how to get across and a frog
happened by and the Scorpion said frog
let me climb on your back and you can
set across the river and you can drop me
off on the other side of the Frog said
no no no if I do that you'll sting me
and I'll drown and the Scorpion said why
would I do that if I did that then we
would both drown and the Frog thought
about a four minute in the Frog said was
a really good point okay that's cool so
the Scorpion climbs on the frogs back
and the Frog sets off well halfway
across the river the Scorpions tail
rears up and stings the Frog and while
the frogs veins are filling up with
venom it looks back at the Scorpion and
it said why did you sting me now we'll
both drown and the Scorpion said I can't
help it it's in my nature and that's
crazy thing about the story is because
is essentially this example werewolves
reigns violent nature is who he is it's
a fundamental part of who he has to
ignore that to try to put it in a box
and hide it away in a closet means but
he's not recognizing the warning signs
initially that his son may be moving in
that direction now by the time he begins
to pick these up it's too late and the
way that we learn that is they're
tending to their farm you know there's
of course a goat that they're gonna take
care of and so on and so forth but when
Wolverine goes inside he asked his son
he says what happened to the goat and he
says well it seems like a predator got
to it and that's when Wolverine begins
to realize that his son dagan is moving
towards this direction of being such a
violent individual basically following
the same path that Wolverine himself
Allah when he was younger now from here
we transitioned to the introduction of
Charles Xavier and so this is Rob
Williams saying hey even if I don't give
you a definitive chronology of when
these events take place in terms of
what's going on in the outside world
here's some measure of how things take
place and so it works out really well
because the story is supposed to be
isolated I mean in truth this whole
first half is supposed to be removed
from all the events that are going on
and so we're not supposed to have this
tried-and-true understanding of when
this chronology takes place but when
Xavier shows up of course Wolverine is
like oh my god there's somebody here
because this first thoughts flashed back
to Weapon X you know all that kind of
good stuff and so he says you gotta go
you know get out of here you gotta go
and Charles Xavier essentially offers
him a chance to become part of the x-men
now as we know with regards to the
history of the x-men and in my
explanation on the x-men team and so on
and so forth which I to get back into
character and team explanations but when
Charles Xavier showed up this was after
the original x-men of Iceman and beast
Archangel Jean Grey and Cyclops had been
taken prisoner by the living
of Kokua and so this is essentially
Xavier assembling a new team with
Colossus Nightcrawler the whole nine
yards Edward a rescue the original x-men
team which is where that x-men title
under Chris Claremont began to grow from
but unlike the main earth-616 continuity
where Wolverine says okay yeah sure I'll
join that instead he's like get out of
here go away I do not want the outside
world interfering now the crazy thing
about this is his son of course asome
says who was that man what's going on
Wolverine muses to himself he says well
maybe I should have told him it's a man
from another life maybe I should have
told him it's a guy from the outside
world that leads a school where he wants
to raise people that have abilities to
make sure their abilities are used
adequately this is really Wolverine with
an extreme amount of hubris because
instead of sitting down and saying well
maybe this guy Charles Xavier knows what
he's talking about
maybe the Xavier school for gifted
youngsters and that's the place that
Dakin needs to go to because maybe being
among his own peers will help him to
better understand his own role if
there's a yin and a yang if he's not
around people that don't have healing
factors and that don't have advanced
combat skills and that don't have claws
then it gives him this sort of false
sense of how strong he is but if he is
around people that are just as capable
as he is they could simply just shut
down his mind instead of fighting then
it helps him to understand this place
because this is really what Dakin is
experiencing right now like all
teenagers all of us growing up we're
trying to understand where we reside and
this hierarchy of this social food chain
we're trying to figure out if we're
alpha males beta males we're trying to
figure out if we're alpha females beta
females we're trying to figure out where
we stand when it comes to our place in
the bigger picture but Dakin has no real
challengers it's almost like he's a
predator in a world of prey and so
because of this and we pick up two years
later and he ends up in a monastery yes
they're formidable in their own right
he's told you know by the other kids
around there they're extremely capable
in terms of fighting but they can didn't
take any of them seriously because he
has claws because he has a healing
factor he could kill every last one of
these guys no questions asked he might
sustain a few bruises but his healing
factor I'll take care of all that and so
there's no counterbalance here there's
no one to challenge his superiority and
so it's grown in to the point where he
has a very superior sense of self now
this comes to a head when he begins
talking to a woman named Indira now
there's another kid that steps up and
this kid Georgie I think is how you
pronounce it I'm not sure exactly how to
pronounce that right but he basically
says no no wonder you do not have to
count over this guy you have to do it
he wants you to do will keep you
protected and so what happens as they
can challenges this dude and of course
we end up picking up with this kind of
montage work Rob Williams bounces back
and forth where Wolverine takes off for
a time and he tells us son you're not to
leave the property you're to tend the
land do your chores if I find out you've
done anything other there's gonna be
hell to pay when I get back but we also
learned that during this fight the oh
really day get hit beat this kid within
an inch of his life not only that he had
dished out some severe physical injuries
in terms of cuts and someone and so
forth now this is Rob Williams
unofficially telling us bacon has the
use of his claws because up until this
point we didn't really know and we
didn't know if those had manifested it
off and it's kind of cool that it
happens behind the scenes it's also kind
of interesting the first use of his
cause here are in a very violent
conflict at least as far as we know but
because of all this people are terrified
of them people are horrified of them and
this comes to fruition when we really
have taken just kind of hanging out on
the side of a mountain and then indira
comes to see him and says everybody
wants you guys to leave they're
terrified of you they're horrified of
you they see you as a violent insane
psychopathic animal and they're afraid
you're going to kill everyone and so the
only way for them to cope with that is
to ask you to leave and so you know he
initially says I don't really want to
but in the midst of their discussion
they're suddenly met with the arrival of
Sabretooth now again the saber-tooth in
this story is just as much a physical as
a metaphorical representation of
Wolverine sins coming back to haunt him
and the reason why I say that is because
Sabretooth being a physical presence has
always been a part of Wolverines life
for as long as you can remember going
back to his time as Team X so on and so
forth not only that Sabretooth is just
pure bloodlust
I mean Sabretooth just loves killing
people he has no real connection with
his own humanity and so he has no real
connection with anybody else's humanity
and because of this of course the first
thing he does is cast in der Assad I
send her flying off the side of the
mountain to her death but then he turns
and looks to Dick in and says I'm trying
to get wolve rank but I can smell him on
you I can tell you are his offspring and
so he says the best way to get to him is
to get to you now Daken fights off as
best he can and he's actually pretty
impressive here it's actually pretty
cool to see him hold his own to a degree
against Sabretooth but what he's doing
is he's basically fighting experience
he's fighting a guy that has a vast
amount of experience in all forms of
combat and so try as he might he's
really got nothing against Sabretooth
which of course leads to the return of
Wolverine who steps in now again this is
really kind of a funny situation but the
issue with this is that where Wolverine
is successfully able to base
we kill saber-tooth or at least it seems
like it here we basically jumped forward
a bit to what diggin was doing now Rob
Williams has not give us like this
in-depth explanation as said he just
kind of fast tracks at all and he tells
us that you know following the death of
Indira they can have basically gone to
the monk monastery and slaughtered them
all and this was effectively his
downward spiral because in every story
that's what happens right I mean when
you have like a villain or you have it
like a a villain who is a good guy at
some point in time there's always that
Darth Vader effect you know there's a
point where they stop being a good guy
and they start being a bad guy sometimes
it takes a long time for that transition
to happen but that switch eventually
takes place and this is the switch for
Dakin this is where he starts being
anakin and becomes darth vader this is
where he stops being the son of you know
wolverine and becomes a bad guy and so
because of this he basically takes off
to tokyo nine years after all this had
happened and forms a criminal empire for
himself to the point where he basically
has anything you wanted to now he built
this Empire through fear blood and death
but he was able to build it nonetheless
the problem with this is that once will
reign finally locates taken after
tracking him down for so long he says
look I'm going to offer you the
opportunity to stand down like you you
have to give up here you have to stop
this come back home with me live a life
of peace we can leave all this behind us
and we can call it a day what's ironic
about this is Wolverine still not
learning he's still not learning the
fact that you just can't run away you
can't run away from your problems you
got to face him head-on
daikin is a representation of Wolverines
failures they can his representation of
the fact that Wolverine believes you
could take his darker nature put it in
the corner and act like it didn't exist
it's everything that will rain about his
youth coming back to haunt him and so
because of this you know diggin lashes
out and wolverine responds in kind by
saying I brought a Muramasa blade now
for those of you guys who are new to
Marvel Comics there are several
different aspects several different
weapons that can defeat people who have
healing factors carbonadium can disrupt
healing factors temporarily but it's
really more like putting healing factors
in a state of flux so much as turning
them off the Muramasa blade turns off
healing factors temporarily and so when
a person is touched by a Muramasa blade
their healing factor essentially stops
working for a temporary amount of time
effectively making them human they can
be killed by any normal conventional
means now when it comes to people who
have healing factors the caveat is that
unless you were to like cut off their
head or unless you were to remove their
Artur something like that do something
that would basically keep their body
from functioning in a normal capacity
they're always going to come back after
the effects of the Muramasa blade we're
off now we do not see that to his
fruition here instead Rob Williams
effectively kind of cuts it off with the
idea that will rain was forced to kill
his son but this is really Wolverine
finally recognizing it's him finally
learning that the mistakes that he made
in his life the things that he's screwed
up were an indication of the fact that
he was a guy that could never find peace
Wolverine could never live the life that
he was hoping for he wanted a kid he
wanted a life of happiness he want to be
left alone but the mistakes that he made
the things that he'd done were always
going to come back to haunt him they
were always going to be a part of his
life and ultimately Dakin was a
representation of the fact that will
reign again cannot have a regular normal
average life like a human he was born a
killer and he will die a killer and
that's just how his life exists but if
you guys are new here to comics
explained maishy guys hit the sub button
to become part of the Rob core if you
guys enjoyed this video make sure you
drop a like and yeah leave a comment
down below let me know whether or not
you guys are interested in more digging
stuff and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]